Apple's M2 extreme Mac Pro is coming and
we just got perhaps the biggest leak and
hint at when it is going to be coming
this is the best solidified proof that
we have from a very reliable source that
matches up to other sources as well
including Mark German who I did
interview that I'm going to be talking
about in this video so what I'm going to
cover are these new leaks including the
new PCI Express slot situation and I'm
also going to talk about the new M2 Mac
Mini and what else we should be seeing
coming up in the Apple silicon Mac space
so let's get right into it now I'm not
going to waste your time let's jump
right into the big leak that just
happened yes Apple's rumored to launch
the 27 inch mini LED display a new one
in the first quarter of 2023 that means
between January and March of next year
now this leak comes from Ross young who
is Extreme reliable in terms of Apple
display leaks he's nailed many things
like the display size of the M2 MacBook
Air he nailed the iPad Mini 6 he nailed
the 14 inch 16 inch MacBook Pros with
Pro motion and mini LED he got all of
that correct and because I am a super
follower yes I'm paying five bucks a
month to Ross young I saw this new leak
from him saying that he heard that the
Apple mini LED monitor launch was pushed
to the first quarter of 2023 yes he
literally just said that so because of
that I replied to his tweet saying Mac
Pro in the first quarter of 2023 which
he actually liked my tweet that doesn't
mean anything he liked it however he did
clarify some information by replying to
Ed Hardy saying just to confirm it's a
27 inch with mini LED and 5K he said 27
inch midi LED we know 5K was just a
guess so we know that 27 inch melee LED
for sure so essentially this new display
is going to be just like the 27 inch
Studio display which has 5.5 K
resolution except it's going to come
with many LEDs so it's going to be an
xdr display and maybe it's even gonna
have some extra features like maybe Pro
motion 120 hertz which would be very
very difficult to do so I kind of doubt
that that's coming but I do think it's
going to be a lot more expensive and
definitely high-end for those people who
need the xdr 1600 nits brightness now
these leaks started around a year ago
and here in January 31st of 2022 he said
that they no longer expect Apple's iMac
Pro to launch in the spring it looks
more like summer and still with a mini
LED backlight but fewer zones than an
iPad in MacBook display however then in
March he went on to say that instead of
it actually being an iMac Pro it's more
likely that it's actually just a
high-end display 5K with 27 inch mini
LEDs and here's the kicker rosh young
even said that it could launch in June
alongside a new Mac Pro now that is very
important of course that didn't happen
because he ended up delaying that in may
he ended up saying nope it's no longer
happening in June it's been delayed
again until October because of a
relocation of their suppliers so it was
looking more like in October release
which we are now in October and we're
hearing nothing about that and then of
course we just got the new tweet saying
that it's been pushed again delayed
until the first quarter of
2023. now in terms of these leaks I was
actually talking to Mark German who was
the number one most reliable Apple
leaker out there this is actually our
video being shared on 95 Mac in an
interview he mentioned quite a few
details about the new Mac Pro he says
that it's being delayed until next year
which could be as soon as the first
quarter January through March and the
crazy thing is Ming shuko who is also a
very reliable Apple leaker and he's well
known for his reputation he also last
year in March said that the Mac Pro is
being delayed until
2023 as well as the iMac Pro and the Mac
Mini which for the Mac Mini I actually
disagree with that but I do think the
Mac Pro might not come until next year
just like Ross young is implying and
just like Mark German is saying now Mark
German also gave us some information
about the Chip he says that the M2 Ultra
is headed into the Next Generation Mac
Pro as well as the M2 extreme which is
basically double the specs of the ultra
up to 48 cores for the CPU 160 core GPU
that is absolutely insane potentially
160 cores and 384 gigs of RAM those are
some absolutely insane specs and I think
they're going to be up there with
nvidia's top of the line cards like the
40 90 in terms of the GPU performance
but what's really special about the Mac
Pro leaks is we actually have an
exclusive anonymous source that posted
to Mac numerous forums and his name is
amethyst now check this out the reason
he's reliable is because way back on
March 3rd he actually leaked and said
that there would be a new workstation
class Mac called the Mac Studio and of
course at Apple's March 8th event five
days later they revealed the Max studio
which was basically exactly what he was
saying it would be even right down to
the low end Mac display that would be an
apple 5K display looking kind of similar
to the Apple Pro display xdr which those
details were correct so he got that
right but then he came back in July with
some brand new details about the Apple
silicon Mac Pro and you might be
wondering how did he get this
information well he has a friend that
actually has access to the Prototype MAC
machines which they likely have some
kind of software company that Apple made
a partnership with them to test it out
and show it off in their marketing so he
has a friend where he got these leaks
from so let's go through the details
it's going to have a total of 40 CPU
cores 32 performance cores and eight
efficiency cores which is exactly what
Mark German was saying and the
interesting thing is that he said
there's a sample board that contains a
PCI Express slot but at the time when he
was testing it it was not working
however he did add the detail that it
was just a prototype board and he
believed that the production unit may
include more than just the single PCI
Express slot which of course makes the
most sense but the confirmation here is
that Apple was testing the new Mac Pro
with an apple silicon chip and PCI
Express slots at the same time which is
very good news for modularity now the
interesting thing is that he just came
back in August with some details about
the M2 Mac Mini which make complete
sense and match up to some other leakers
first of all he said he just got some
info about the new Mac Mini it's going
to have the same design basically the
same Parts just a change in the soc
slash threads that is a very very
interesting detail to add because if you
match that up to some information that
we got in my interview with Mark German
markerman said that the Mac Mini
redesign is unlikely so there's no
redesign it's going to have the same
chassis and that makes the most sense
because you're going to be able to put a
regular M2 Chip which has been leaked
and the M2 Pro chip which Mark German in
August also said Mac Mini with M2 and Mt
Pro chips still in the works and that
perfectly matches up with what amethyst
said that it's going to change the soc
and the threads which of course the
threads means that there needs to be two
separate chip options in that Mac Mini
which is exactly what Mark German was
saying and I believe I fully believe
that it's coming either later this month
or potentially next month I think that
makes the most sense for this new
machine to come out and the reason I
believe that is because way back in
February we had three new Mac regulatory
filing numbers and the crazy thing is
that one of them was the Mac Studio
which we of course got in March the
other one was the laptop which was the
M2 MacBook Air redesign and the third
one we still have not seen it and I
fully believe that the third one is the
new M2 Mac Mini machine and then of
course we also got some details from
both Mark German and digitimes who
believe that the new 14 and 16 inch
MacBook Pros are launching later this
year which I think they're most likely
happening this month of course for a
long time I thought they were going to
get delayed until next year in March
because they would come with three
nanometer chips but now I think with
everything going on in the world with
inflation and everything else I think it
makes sense for Apple to Simply take the
easy and cheap route and just launch it
this year with a lackluster chip this is
not going to be a worthwhile upgrade for
anybody that already has the 14 or 16
inch MacBook Pro I don't think it's
going to be a big deal but I think the
way apple is going to Market this is by
marketing the M2 Pro and M2 Max chips as
new four nanometer chip so instead of
five nanometer they're four nanometer
which is basically a small Improvement
compared to the five nanometer chips
that we've already have but it's all
about marketing so I think this month
potentially we're going to have the new
Mac Mini with the M2 Pro and regular M2
Chip would have the new 14 and 16 inch
MacBook Pros with the M2 Pro and M2 Max
chips and we may even see an
announcement maybe even next month at a
potential November event of that new Mac
Pro and then that would mean it would
start shipping potentially in January or
apple is just literally gonna wait until
March of next year to have their March
event where they release the new Apple
silicon Mac Pro with that new display
which was leaked I think it only makes
sense for Apple to launch this new
display if it's coming alongside a new
Mac and since the Mac Mini is coming
this year potentially this month I think
the only Mac that this very high-end
expensive xdr display could not lunch
with is the Mac Pro and that is why I
fully believe that Ross young got it
right this display is launching
alongside the Mac Pro in the first
quarter of 2023 so if you completely
disagree with me let me know down in the
comment section below but if you enjoyed
the video click the circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
and check one out right over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]
thank you